Emory Saint Joseph's
Chief Heart Surgeon Douglas Murphy
gets ready to repair a patient's heart valve.
Along with his surgical team, he'll be assisted by
a Da Vinci surgical robot.
Murphy: "What the patient sees is fast recovery --
out of the hospital, like 3 days,
playing golf in like 3 weeks,
and cosmetically the scar is minimal.
But that's not the reason we do it.
The reason we do it is because we can do
the operations better because we can see better."
From a console, the surgeon performs the operation
remotely while observing the scene through a
stereoscopic monitor, which provides a
magnified view in 3D. And that's not all.
Halkos: "By coming through the right chest
with robotic technology and instrumentation
we're able to see the valve better,
and because we're able to see it better,
we're able to perform more precise technical
maneuvers to repair valves."
Along with Murphy, Emory's Chief of Cardiothoracic Surgery
Michael Halkos, routine share information and help train
other heart surgeons from around the world
on robotic surgical practices.
Halkos: "We believe it provides a benefit to patients
and we want more patients
to be able to enjoy that benefit.
The robot uses several arms,
essentially high-tech surgical tools
that are inserted into the patient's torso
through small incisions.
Murphy: "We can fix the mitral valve, the tricuspid valve,
we can take out tumors, we can repair holes in the heart,
and other miscellaneous little defects --
and we do it through five little holes.
In addition, the tools respond to the natural dexterity of the human hand,
giving surgeons and impressively steady and accurate touch.
Murphy: "The robot has software that eliminates tremor,
so you can reach way in to work on a heart valve,
and your hand is incredibly steady.
And just like the human arm,
the robotic arm has the wrist at the distal end,
we call it, inside the patient."
Patients also appear to be less susceptible to
surgical site infections.
Murphy: "We're just not seeing it.
So infections is zero. We've eliminated that problem."
But a robotic surgical project is a major investment
and may not be practical for all hospitals.
Murphy: "Robotics is not for everybody.
Robotics is for big institutions
that have the resources,
that live in a relatively populated area,
so there's a lot of patients who can potentially benefit.
And it'll be like mitral valve repair centers of excellence.
That's where it'll fit in.
It's not going to be done in small towns
where they do five a year."
But for large teaching hospital systems like Emory,
this type of advanced technology makes perfect sense.
Halkos: "Without bragging, Emory's cardiac robotics program
is the largest program in the United States  and probably in the world.